whoa that's a mistake 2.6 seconds ago
now late Griffin will turn
[Applause]
you believe it is again we're going to
watch it Blake Griffin oh he steps
behind
always culture what a bounce what a
bounce it doesn't have enough trajectory
to go in does it hits the front of the
rim I guess it's his night then old man
his second three of the game is that
official yet Tom Washington takes off
that touch three-point mastered slippers
well it's official Redick right point of
the Johnston's with two was blocked
a 3-ball by Blake Griffin tanana rolling
the shot clock winding down he realizes
it catch and shoot and even Blake had to
smile over that one oh yeah airball mood
a gets it pour in the clock you have to
do it himself
bingo by Blake Griffin mood was always
in his ears in eight keep at it you
never know when this thing is gonna
break and you're gonna regain your hope
we're gonna need you nice shot outside
by Griffin made it all NBA defensive
team once rivers up top Griffin Griffin
fakes fires hits
Blake Griffin is second three-pointer
out to Griffin nine the shot clock 1:40
to go in the game
drop it back to Blake we're shooting the
three-ball bingo they were post up 10
then they evolved into Parker and
Ginobili they were a pick and roll team
Griffin 4:3 dreamed of a set for man
down the 3-ball looks to the angry boy
he was there they couldn't get a tube
drippin terrific burger
and a huge jury his third of the night
obviously a lot of potential still there
in porzingis that make you strikes this
season all back to Jay judge Griffin for
his fourth of the game bring go most
ever
what spot which means home ports in the
first round of the playoff likely
they'll play the Jazz either way that
position of bringing Rodney hood off the
bench after Rodney hírtv's Griffin will
try a three
he's 2 for 10 Lou Williams looks ahead
gets the ball to Griffin he'll turn with
4 seconds to go
works on Chris ducks back for three
Blake Griffin's third and three ball of
the game his sixth and two games
these size up his Mane beautifully check
your seatbelts here we go
Griffon at distance
Blake Griffin knocks down a three but
slippers escape Rose City with the wind
they will review this to make sure we
got off in time for the red lights light
up around the board he has it easily in
time the Clippers get the victory by a
final tally and an unbelievable October
fuller they defeat the Portland Trail
Blazers 104 to 103 Blake Griffin
knocking down his second three ball of
the basketball game and let the joy
begin
[Music]
[Applause]
Griffin checks o'clock checks his rhythm
fires a storage Blake Griffin with nine
eight in the clock
Melo's checks the clock it's at five
they still have to do it again who Bango
Blake Griffin has beaten the buzzer
twice with dagger three balls in this
bother New Orleans pelicans Clippers up
by six
Bullock closed out on by ciacco here's
Griffin
for the tie yes cold-blooded take the
pressure because he knows the balance
two sticks is going to drive this finds
Blake Griffin in the corner drop it - it
goes a [ __ ] for Blake Griffin elated
his holding now it's not hesitation and
there's a difference knocked off running
down to the piston Blake Griffin with
two on the clock had to go get it now
the log on it goes a triple for blank
beat the buzzer
he already has made up his mind this is
a open invitation for three and I'm
gonna can this thing 250 left play
Griffin stops
[Applause]
- the plague in overtime Blake Griffin
squares up it season it goes
a triple Bert Blake and then here look
at his stepping a little screen to help
get the separation hollis-jefferson goes
underneath that screenplay credit
perfectly Bruce brown off the plate
rippers pops it - you'll have to fire
dogs it fills it up that great girl for
the heat that hit to the chest may have
helped create the rhythm into that
little fade away shot for Blake Martin
now Ross has played grip the shot clock
inside five he'll square up the gun for
three and it's through
[Applause]
with the Pistons have a two-point lead
system leads a rocket 98-96 a clutch
triple for Blake Griffin it will be
cousins back after the holidays
[Applause]
outside three is true very appreciative
some biscuits lessons those they called
her on way outside Blake Griffin long
sweet so one of those shots you'd need
maybe to stop a losing streak Reggie
Jackson whips a pass to Blake Griffin
over Randall for free and it's through
Lake Griffin almost lost it shot clock
down to two have to fire no problem it's
on Ruby Oh his first Blake allowed spate
[Music]
that light rod comes with three it's
true that's his move there that is fifty
to move with three Potter burns down 17
to nine they'll take time out makes the
shot five on the clock for Blake Griffin
burn fires fills it
comes up with a set like that Pompey and
foul in the clutch here's Crowder with
the hip would you get what they want
Blake Griffin for three funny moment
plenty of big-money moments for Blake
Griffin matter of fact he was four for
four
there is deep position without the ball
[Music]
[Applause]
Lake comes up fires fills it up that was
a beautiful play right delay Griffin
finished off a beautiful play remember
the double screen they set in Toronto
but it was Reggie Bullock going to the
basket who got the pass and triple what
home business now lead by seven down to
five he's got Horford on him this Lake a
long long three inch through game I
anticipated I didn't expect a blowout
I expected a hard
go to the outside the Blake clocks at
6,000 the screen late miss bring it up
sir the [ __ ] goes down to one point
three three screens Andrey screams Blake
shot he hits it from behind the long
line jill has no real arm three seconds
left in the half
long gun the first half for him for
boiling for basketball right now Blake
Griffin triples he continues to add to
his career-high
deceptive food drives the double Griffin
shot Parkinson is gonna have to fire
who's got the best
oh my goodness that step after we here
and here's the step back shot clock
running down
bad leg and all so stuck out seven out
of eight core is tied
plate for three what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content